why pick on this machinist
why pick on this salesgirl
why pick on this housewife
why pick on this stupid
well we didn't what TV did TV what is TV
TV is tuberculosis it's catching it
respects no age sex class or race TV
breeds and neglect overcrowding bad
housing conditions but TV can be
anywhere in the slums or on the avenue
it thrives on ignorant of the facts
it is insidious tireless it can exist
unknown among you because it shows no
outward signs of course you're healthy
you think it can't happen to you but TB
might happen to you without warning once
it catches up with you TB can slow you
down to a standstill
you can't see the TB germ with the naked
eye but here behind the scenes these
people know what it looks like on the
slide under the microscope are some
germs coughed up by a TB patient how
about a doctor may we have a look
here it is the tubercle bacillus the
germ that causes tuberculosis medical
scientists study the effect of the
tubercle bacillus the tape a germ that
destroys vital tissues of the human body
always seeking weapons to combat the
invader here's the kind of damage it
does and it is only when TB is well
along that it shows itself in
unexplained tiredness loss of weight
coughing and importantly spitting up
blood
this hand belongs to a person who has TB
you may think he looks like this
but the hand belongs to him surprised
you sodas TV you see in the early stages
TV masquerades you can't tell it and
neither can the other fellow this man
doesn't deliberately mean to endanger
the lives of those to whom he works but
spray containing TB germs scatters
several feet away reaches the nose and
mouth of a healthy person that's you the
home with its close family contacts is
the ideal ground for spreading TB germs
but remember you're not born with TB you
get it from someone who has it
everything this parent uses and touches
in the home may spread deadly TB germs
yet all the while he is completely
unaware that he is exposing his family
to infection dancing music romance all
will soon be forgotten if this girl has
picked up TB from her father for sooner
or later she will spread the disease to
others
this is the way she season but behind
the familiar face in that healthy body
what's the inside story only the doctor
can tell if you have TB and there's a
chance remember that you do have it
he'll give you a complete physical
examination at your per keulen test if
indicated and most important of all a
chest x-ray without x-ray many people
today would still be in the dark become
sick before they knew they had TB only
the x-ray can look behind that picture
of health you present and see what's
underneath what's that doctor a shadow
that shouldn't be there lucky you found
it before it got any worse when you had
that picture taken you did yourself a
favor and by going to the sanatorium
you'll do your family a favor with his
TB discovered in the early stages a
patient can walk into the sanatorium
under his own power and be pretty
certain of walking out again alive and
well
trow he is isolated in the sanatorium
nearest to his home but it's a friendly
isolation he's with fellow patients
whose problems and objectives are the
same as his own
his family and friends are free to visit
him and he is taught that the treatment
for TB is rest in bed plus good food
fresh air in the sanatorium the TB
patient learns how to live food is
selected to meet the requirements of the
individual patient he is given periodic
examinations his physical condition is
constantly studied by his doctor he gets
the best medical and nursing care
surgery if he needs it and a thing vital
to his peace of mind he doesn't spread
TB to those he loves if the old job is
too strenuous the patient is in the
right spot to train for a new job
occupational therapy yes the practical
kind that prepares the patient for work
that he enjoys worthwhile work that he
can handle without endangering his
future health
time rest relaxation and work wonders by
following his doctor's orders this man
got well nice going there and now to
keep well
you can do it but remember you must
check with your doctor regularly
from coast-to-coast from border to
border and over the border in cities
towns on farms TB is present right now
at least half a million Americans have
TB the death toll is well over 50,000
lives each year if you want to avoid TB
find out where you can get a chest x-ray
get one now urge everyone you know to
have one
make a chest x-ray of part of your
thorough physical checkup have that
checkup at least once a year you'll live
longer
who is the next patient doctor
he isn't always the person in the
waiting room
the next patient might be that man
crossing the street
maybe he should be heading this way to
make sure he hasn't got TB
that's it you'll never regret your
action mister you're on the beam and
you're travelling in the right direction
you